hello welcome to the channel in the
video I am your host Matt thanks for
tuning in as you know by the title this
is 10 things that you begin to notice
the more and more you program and the
first thing is you begin to think more
about how machines work especially
automated machines I was that to Kroger
today and I went to the automated
checkout and I noticed it when you it
tells you to place your stuff in the bag
and you set it in there and it knows and
if you remove stuff it knows and I was
thinking about it from a programmers
perspective how it does the weight and
it sounds pretty straightforward you
play something in there it checks the
weight but there's always gonna be
little variations so it's gonna have to
do things like accommodate for a small
error so the more you do programming and
the more you think about problem solving
the more you will realize that these
automated machines always have to
account for small error in pretty much
disregard because if the weight suddenly
shifts by yeah just a tiny fraction of a
pound it's probably not a big deal and
they don't want to throw an error in
that case number two everything's an
algorithm I always think about this when
I'm driving
oddly enough nearly every task you do
can be broken down into an algorithm
with driving I always think of staying
on the road basically how you drive to
work around traffic that can all be
worked out into some kind of precise
algorithm but also when you think about
something like throwing a ball you begin
to realize how it arcs and how the speed
changes and there's a specific algorithm
to that and it's like that for nearly
everything and the more you get into
programming and studying the algorithms
the more you start to to look at just
little everyday things and think there's
a specific mathematical algorithm behind
that and it's just for some of the sorta
just happens after a while probably
happens more to like game programmers
then
than other types and number three how
difficult artificial intelligence is I
used to think artificial intelligence
can't be that hard just a bunch of UF
else statements pretty much right I
think it's a little more complicated
than that it's a lot more complicated
than that you see the problem with it is
there's just so many cases and you could
never really have every case and in the
program they would just take there's a
couple of problems and a couple reasons
why you pretty much have to make general
cases that cover the majority of things
and they have to be general enough to
cover a variety of cases all at once for
example if you think about let's see
what's a good example well let's go back
to cars the problem of self-driving cars
most of them just do distance checking
and sides of the road checking some
basic things like that to keep going and
they use data from from GPS and map
student it to know what the speed limit
is and it's pretty straightforward with
just those few things but they can never
really account for every single little
thing like do they check for things
above the car and think oh something's
about to fall on the car I better move I
don't know probably not but hey I isn't
as simple as it might seem once you
begin to think about every little case
and the many errors that could happen
and how that can affect more cases
coming forward going forward it's it's a
little more complicated than that and I
think the better you get at programming
the more you start to see that most most
games for example only use just
pathfinding pretty much and some basic
player tracking and
there's really not a whole lot of things
behind him it's pretty difficult to make
it really elaborate and make it human
like number four imposter syndrome is
real I think every developer experiences
this pretty heavily and I thought a lot
about it there's no real easy way to
overcome it
programming is just kind of hard when
you get really into it and there's
always more to learn and I think that's
why it often takes a day or two to solve
a problem that you would hope to solve
rather quickly and you know when that
happens you begin to feel like maybe
you're not good enough that maybe you're
not fit for this for this task
and that's basically impostor syndrome
and you've really just got to learn to
keep trying and push through and that's
what makes a good developer if you give
in to that impostor syndrome well then
you are an impostor because well maybe
you're not because you you admitted that
you couldn't do it so that doesn't make
you an impostor anymore I don't know
there's a weird conundrum there but it's
a real thing that pretty much all
developers and all difficult problem
solvers face is they eventually
encounter something that's not easy to
solve and if they feel like maybe
they're not cut out for it I think it
happens to a lot of people in their
careers but it's just a syndrome
you can push past it and almost
everybody can push past it just don't
give up and just keep researching
number five why programmers are paid so
well this is something you begin to
realize when you've been doing
programming for a while there's there's
so much to learn about programming it's
so much to know and it's pretty much
just a non-stop non-stop thing there's
not very many people who can do it and
stick it out long term and really solve
the challenges that need to be solved in
a in a big company or in a big program
so that's why developers tend to get
paid so much is yeah those two reasons
they're really rare and there's a lot of
competition for the few good ones that
are out there
number six
you never get a chance to stop learning
as a developer you really don't you know
I always assumed when I first started a
program that eventually I would hit a
limit where I kind of know everything
and could do everything but now that
I've been doing it for a while and feel
like I'm decent enough to accomplish
most tasks within a reasonable time I'm
starting to notice that it never ends
it's an endless endless knowledge hole
and I actually like that because I tend
to get bored of things that get easy so
for me it's a good thing but to others
they they might feel a little
discouraged by that don't be discouraged
just specialize instead is what I would
recommend as you can at least get really
good in one area and you can depend on
friends or coworkers or other people for
other areas and there's no way you're
gonna do everything it's just not really
even possible
so another reason you should specialize
did a video about that a couple videos
back if you want to hear more about why
you should specialize number what is
this one two three four five six
seven number seven only other technical
people truly understand what you do I
can see this
I always thought programmers were I
don't know like you see on Grandma's Boy
the guy with the I can't remember his
name always thought programmers were
like that they just were in some other
world where they're doing something
that's not even possible to normal
people but that's not true and once you
start to learn about programming you
start to understand what they do but
until you kind of get into programming
it is very difficult to relate to your
work to other people's work because it's
just so different and I don't know I
don't know what to say about that but it
does seem to be a thing number eight
making video games ain't easy what ends
up happening to most people almost every
developer I've talked to you all the P a
lot of the kids I went to school with
and even the people in my job now
everyone wants to make a really cool
game but it's not easy it's quite
difficult you have to have a really
advanced knowledge of of algorithms and
linear algebra and not only that you
have to learn quite a quite a few
libraries to get things integrated
correctly making simple games is pretty
easy but when you start to try to make
big games especially like I don't know
like a like a first-person triple-a game
you start to realize how much stuff was
involved with the animations and getting
all the logic right and the collision
and the math and making sure people
don't fall through the world and go
through walls it requires a lot of
processing power and you got to do it
just right so that it actually can run
at 60 frames per second it's quite a
difficult thing most people end up
getting normal more normal day jobs
maintaining things rather than the
developing games just because developing
games is so hard and it requires so much
time
I'm actually aiming to be a game
developer in the long run so I try to
take on incredible challenges as often
as I can I'd recommend the same but it's
very brutal and it's not for everybody
number nine how much time it takes to
build something good as this kind of
relates to the game thing but it does
usually when you come up with an idea
you can think of a few core things about
it that are would make it kind of good
enough and once you implement those you
start to see all kinds of other little
problems and other little holes and how
it could actually be improved to be more
usable and it ends up taking quite a bit
of effort in time to make it truly
usable I really like making little tools
and it seems like that's a useful thing
but those are only really good in a
little little niche environment so to
make something that's truly a great
piece of software or a great game it's
gonna take a lot of time the more you
program the more you start to see that
and last but not least why good design
is needed before you start to code when
I was a new developer I would get an
idea and I would jump straight in there
trying to code it only to be lost and
confused an hour in thinking about where
was I going with this what do I need to
do next to make this work right
you start to realize as you get more
experienced that you really need to have
a good design in place and that will
save you a lot of time because you won't
be rethinking in the middle and trying
to think of the ideas you had earlier
and and how you were putting them into
place so that's that's another thing is
to just get really good at design and
that makes a big difference for for
coders I think also that's why you see
in most projects you see designers and
then you see programmers you it's rarely
the programmer that's also the designer
and I think the reason for that is just
programmers have to spend so much time
just knowing the technology that often
when they come up with an idea they
implement it in a very basic tool like
way but it's often not designed well
enough to be truly usable so you really
got to have a good designer in place to
to keep the programmer on task and doing
the right thing well that's all ten of
my things that you start to realize when
you become the more your program I hope
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
give it a like and subscribe to the
channel if you're not already subscribed
I'll see you in the next one
keep coding